okay ready and one two hold on two three
[Music]
wow four i missed that jake we had two
podcasts without that
and i know and i did the guitar for a
while and people were not happy about
that
so there were so many down to stop
yeah dude it's real the the banjo
has a tune yeah all in it's all of its
own
and then it just gets everybody else
amped like it gets us all amped to talk
about
uh you know current events current
events
welcome to the current events podcast
during these uncertain times
during these challenges oh my god that's
what we were just joking about
beforehand if i
hear dirt if i hear now more than ever
one more time in a commercial i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna flip
insurance company marketing people just
are having a heyday
and just trying to make me feel better
by putting this
garbage in your commercial imagery of
family staying at home and
waving at the camera you know what i
would appreciate in a good insurance ad
be like hey guys we we accept a lot of
claims you know
some of them probably others wouldn't
accept
and uh you know we've got pretty good
rates and uh
with us you know things are probably
going to be better for you so
yeah i'm sure you would want to hear
there it is but i just want to see a dog
with a mask
that's really all i need insurance yeah
it's called a muzzle
oh a muzzle yeah
i love having the footage of those
commercials all the families are happy
at home together
like the moms are like you know putting
blankets over their children oh yeah
dinner table like giving them tea as
they study
yeah how do we get these kids out of the
house they can't leave i wonder how much
like
weird dark [ __ ] is going to happen like
we're going to find out about
after the fact like years later after
covid like yeah
they're just going to find like hundreds
of kids went missing yeah yeah and their
parents
or it's like it's a serial killers like
playground really you know
you're just like you kill him in the
house and then you just leave him there
and no one no one
no one was the wiser no no it's just
like start plotting i'm taking
things for later don't worry guys i just
came to this conclusion
the lockdown murderer yeah the lockdown
murderer
oh that's us all right how's that been
for you man with kids at home like being
with your kids
and your family 24 7. how's that been
during cover dude i mean i'm already
working
out of my house so true that's true i
don't know if it's any different
true true maybe maybe it is no i
i i don't honestly it gets it gets a
little rambunctious around here
when the kids are screaming in the
background and sometimes i'm in the
middle of the call and
it's like there's like oh yeah
kid noise coming in oh no doubt
scratches at the door
yeah scratches on the wall um
just have you ever thought about getting
an office
like a separate office space yeah i've
thought about it
just just build yourself one yeah on the
battlefield build a little
you know out outdoor sort of shed like
an outhouse
make yourself a shutout make yourself a
tiny office i might i'm looking at i'm
looking at like
maybe doing something that's where
there's like a
a degree of removal between my bedroom
and my that's the worst man studio when
you're just in your bedroom all day long
like
you're in your bed sleeping then you
just like walk across the room and
there's your yes
oh my gosh dude this summer was horrible
yeah i had to
earlier earlier when we were all
quarantined uh quarantining
i had to like dress up i had to like
dress up the way that i do
you're like i'm in a button up and i'm
like yeah yeah you guys saw me like in
button-ups and stuff yeah i know
and like it's just like i it gets you in
a
mental place definitely work yeah i i
still do that like i
i i do my regular routine that i used to
do when i was commuting every day i i
get up i
work out i take out here i take my kids
to school so i do that and then
i shower and get ready and put my normal
work clothes on
and like i gel my hair and like
you know get ready to leave the house
and then i go to work drive around the
block a couple of times
you know drive around
just create your own traffic yeah yeah
just getting mad at you
call my neighbor and be like hey uh uh
bob can you uh
can you get out there with the uh with
the wrangler
yeah i guess just go real slow yeah
just drive behind him and honk and can
you throw a trash can in the middle of
the road just to surprise you
just drive like one mile an hour down
the road for me like right in front of
me
and then i pay my other neighbor who's
got like a fast car
to drive and cut people off yeah
[Laughter]
the things we do in these uncertain
times in these challenging times
now more than ever now more than ever
again
everyone needs a helping hand everyone
needs to help again
from this insurance company like
guy you know they don't the thing that
irks me is just you know that they don't
really care
you know yeah it's like if you really
cared anyway i just feel like
honesty is the best policy at least they
haven't never had literally not a good
politician
it's nowhere in the world how do we make
more money
yeah that's three things can we screw
you over yeah
how do we get more subscribers and
fulfill less claims
yeah here we go hey but we haven't even
talked about who's on the podcast oh my
god oh yeah
who's who is that who is here today guys
we're like five minutes in and we
haven't even
introduced ourselves because we're all
good buddies yeah um
i know well there's nick here look at
you here i am
you haven't been on the podcast i was
telling him i was sitting at my desk and
ren tapped me on the shoulder and said
you want to be in a podcast i'm like yep
and then i poop
you materialize oh yeah as i'm getting
them to come down to the podcast rena's
like well you know what
he was like i was really getting to the
flow of things he was like sam
and sam was like no and he was like nick
[Laughter]
i'm the thirsty thirds over here thirsty
thirds dude
the sloppy sexy
[Music]
on the cast before and you know i gotta
say jordan
you're uh you're a surprise fan favorite
i think since your first time on the
core crew show
um a lot of activity a lot of buzz
so how does it feel to be corridor
famous now
yeah i was like does it get into your
head no
no especially when i'm the one reading
all the emails and everyone's just
obsessed about everyone else
my name is like nowhere to like can i
please
[Music]
[Laughter]
i've got some questions uh jordan that i
think the audience would like to know as
well
oh gosh uh first first question is um
what's it what's it like uh i think
being the only female in an office full
of dudes
is that uh you know
what's going on there it's easy it's
easy women and i
because i am a woman i know we can be
let me use my words wisely
yeah don't call yourself out yet we can
kind of be a lot we got a lot of moving
parts happening
we're females you know we're running the
world what can i say yeah
so men i have found are a little more
simplistic
just even in the way that like they eat
other than dean because he uses
chopsticks for everything and his rice
cooker it's
absurd but chopsticks equal smart
no dude i love it
yeah it's so easy it's so simple
everyone just like comes in is happy
does their job makes really sick
stuff yeah hell yeah dude i love it
there's no complaints i mean the toilet
seat yeah the toilet situation
well now we have like four bathrooms
because then it's like i have to touch
the toilet seat and i'm like well now my
homes are dirty
like before i even yeah it's a whole
thing and i went around and asked a
couple of them
can you pee without lifting the seat up
yeah that was
you should just you should just use your
foot you know you know
like harness that monkey like come on
maybe that's how
us guys in our in our monkey minds can
help you
yeah monkey minds utilize the feet
sometimes
it's fun yeah yeah yeah yeah why don't
you do the work
we can't we can't be bothered to think
about putting seats down and that's just
another part of my job here
hygiene is a is a real problem amongst
males
yeah it is unfortunate if i was working
with more females i wouldn't be
as messy sometimes like the dishes will
be in really weird places here
really weird sometimes it's fun just to
see where you can put them and how long
they stay there
it's kind of like a game seriously
that's a real thing there are some
things in the studio not dishes in
particular but there are some
items in the studio that have literally
been sitting there for years
for instance there is a box of random
crap from ren's desk that's sitting in a
in a
clear like foot by six inch shoe bin
that's sitting on the i believe it's
still there
we can check right after this but it's
sitting on the
windowsill of the plexiglas windows
of this camera room yeah looking at the
loading dock
it's never gonna be it will never i
don't know what's in it
why it's been there i tried to throw it
away one time and ren got real
oh yeah i'm pretty about it
don't move that time capsule dude
i just found uh i just found a box so
jake
i i was looking for a sander under under
the work bench in the workshop
okay and dude that's like an old mummy
tomb man there's i
i found a box full of cmike's broken
dreams
in the form of his his overhead camera
rig
it's like all perfectly preserved like
he ripped it down
off the wall and just like
disappointedly shoved it in the box
and then you left it there for years and
then
you blew off the sedimentary layers of
the wood dust
we got a problem with that so i could
believe that or maybe it's a tradition
it's a hoarding game it's a hoarding
i'm so thankful that we found you
because like yeah just not only do you
have
a great attitude and you're a hard
worker and you're smart
but also like that was one of my main
concerns
was it's funny because our the first
person
um we ever hired uh was this
um uh young woman named amanda who used
to help us with
all kinds of stuff everything from
costumes to
um production logistics to everything
and then
um she uh eventually moved back
up north and then um and then we went on
like a hiring streak
um but it was all guys and so i it got
to the point where it was like
well i didn't i didn't want to like
you know hire a
woman or hire like a guy just based on
their gender or something i was just
kind of hoping that through the process
of like
the company growing and like finding the
right people
like all of those sort of like you know
things you'd look for
uh to just make sure that like the
company itself has a healthy balance of
perspectives and peoples
is is inherent in in like the process
you know um and so
like but i was starting to get to point
i was kind of getting concerned i was
like
are we just doomed to just be like
helpless dudes forever
you know or are we gonna find somebody
that has like some
pizzazz and like snap and some different
perspectives like
that can come into the studio and
participate and like
join the way that
everyone else has and so i don't know i
just feel like you've done a great job
doing that
and um thank you yeah i don't know yeah
i just wanted to say that
and yeah um it's also really nice having
somebody else
in the studio other than myself that
like
has the uh you know attention to
to the little details on everything you
know like
just everything from like hey where
should we put the camera
the nest camera to like hey what what
are like some of the extra things we're
going to do for like the um
the end of the year party yeah or um you
know
little things that i used to do that i'm
not there anymore like
at least not every day i'm the new jake
i was carrying a pocket knife on my
dreams yeah yeah and i was like wow yeah
it's happening you just need to get it
camo'ed
and then yeah and then you're just a
mustache yeah
i had i i finally got a leatherman two
years ago oh there you go
yeah yeah and these things i'll get you
one maybe okay
yeah yeah when's your birthday may 29th
okay it's coming up that's the most dad
gift i've ever heard in my entire
[Laughter]
yeah wait so do you got you got a pocket
knife because
of the work that you've been doing at
the studio well my dad had given me one
like he's fantastic i mean he's in the
military so he has really good big
knives
so i found it under my bed because i
never use it and i was like oh my gosh
like
i could be ripping through packages
that's all i do it's like every other
five minutes i'm
opening something building you will
quickly learn
that super helpful working here maybe
not as much now than it used to be
because we have like
literally nicer facilities now but
you'll ruin every pair of clothes that
you wear to work
oh yeah and you'll need a knife yeah and
jake just sorry quick interjection i
have a sad story to tell you jake
we'll get right back to what we're
talking about but remember like four
years ago when we went in that knife
store
yeah and on the vlogs and we bought
pocket knives oh dude i carried that
thing every day with me
i don't know dude just last week man
when i was at the airport tsa took it
man oh
i forgot it was in my bag and my
favorite knife dude my favorite knife
got taken from me so rip knife son
i'm so sorry you were the only i mean
hey the nice thing is like
they probably never even got a chance to
open it nick because
yeah it took no one else knew how to
open that thing probably probably not it
was so hard
you probably got flagged yeah this guy's
suspicious yeah
no it had it had one of these like thumb
opening things on yeah
nick was that knew how to actually
open it oh you had the phone i trained
for literally a year to
be able to flick it open like a cool guy
yeah you know but you had the thumb
technique man
so i can be like yeah check out my knife
dude now it's another year of training
now what are you going to do with this
you have thumb knowledge that no one
else has
i'm losing my edge though man well
anyway that's a sad story but everyone
should have a leatherman maybe i should
pick one up as well now
yeah cause uh hey i'll get one for you
too you're gonna like it oh what
yeah you're gonna love it i'm honored
matt you want one too matt you're gonna
love it yeah i mean i'm i'm here so
okay all right if you're giving another
skit around yeah
i hope mine has a bow
a bow a bow just a little bit just like
a permanent one yeah
so that i know it's a dad gift i thought
you meant like i thought you meant like
no not no i thought you meant like a
little bow
a tiny little bow a little tiny bow tie
for toothpick
i love that dude we should make a a
instead of a swiss army knife we should
make like an american army knife dude
like a little gun on there
a little bow for bow hunting a little m4
it jams on you
for no apparent reason you gotta like
mess with it to get into
jam and other insects oh
man oh yeah well leatherman if you're
listening
yeah let's get some changes for you so
guys um how was your christmas
and your new year and everything we
haven't even talked about that on the
podcast yet
but no not really 2020 is over this is
the second podcast of the year
wow yeah well this is an interesting
time for us to talk about
our florida yeah so we're both from
florida yeah
me and matt yeah um you're a real
florida i went to go see my mom in
florida
and immediately got sick oh yeah yeah
yeah
but it was fine well half the time i
didn't know i had it
and then yeah
you may or may not get covered jordan
got the vid yo
yeah yeah like as soon as i got like on
the plane or the airport once
then i gave it to my mom and then we
were just chilling at the house
when did you first know you had buddies
two days after
i got there i had symptoms for only like
36 hours
and then it went away and so i was like
oh maybe it was just like a 24-hour flu
and then i went and got tested a couple
days after my symptoms tested negative
so we're like oh you're good yeah that's
what you think
luckily you had time to quarantine oh
yeah
i wasn't infectious because i'm like
doing my contact tracking and the person
that picked me up from the airport when
i landed in la
i didn't give it to them but technically
i i got back to la tested
i tested positive so it's just like but
my infectious period was probably super
short because my symptoms only lasted
for like a day
right okay and i know it just it varies
between everybody like
when you become infectious when you
start showing symptoms how long you're
infectious
didn't you say you weren't like feeling
it very much or you didn't
yeah i only had a fever so how did you
know
well i woke up with like the i don't get
headaches the worst migraine of my life
like it didn't go away until all the
symptoms went away so
for 36 hours i had a migraine and then i
felt fatigued i just wanted to keep
going back to sleep
and that was it and my mom took my
temperature 101.6 was the highest
okay okay then but then you went and got
tested and it was negative
yep so two days after my symptoms
started
when it got tested it came back negative
so
yeah i just tested it was it a rapid
yeah they did the nose swab
but the woman said she was like she's
like you may not be like accurate and
i'm like
okay yeah the nose swabs sometimes
if you're positive they don't always
read but if they do read as positive
they're pretty they're more accurate
but they're less false they give less
false positives
oh so but then when i got here i did the
oral swab and it was positive
okay but then i wasn't infectious
anymore by the time i even
tested back here it's crazy when i am
infectious i'm getting a negative test
and so that makes people probably go out
and spread it more and then when i do
get my positive tests i'm like telling
everyone like no actually i'm negative
yeah right the testing is like really
really uncertain as we all know for sure
yeah
it's and that's you never know so you
can't be too safe i guess that's what we
all rely on too
like we rely on those results yeah well
i'm super glad
that uh you um
take care of yourself uh and your health
and
you know and that you're young and that
because of all those things
uh it didn't affect you very much yeah
luckily
yeah it affected my mom a little bit she
actually is still has
like a little cough so she's getting
checked for pneumonia but
she feels much better like all of her
other symptoms are gone but she
definitely had it way worse than me like
her symptoms lasted for almost two weeks
did she lose the taste no none of
neither of us lost our taste our senses
fake news i never had a cough yeah no
the taste thing is real my i know oh
yeah
my uh my kids um
gymnastics teacher got it and
over christmas as well and so she was
out for three weeks like
dealing with it and then quarantining
and all that stuff and she said that
during during that time she lost her
taste and smell for like a week
and so she was eating stuff but you
can't taste or smell it
crazy which is just the weirdest i guess
yeah that's the worst for me because i
love food and
alcohol and i love the taste of those
things because like i like to enjoy
the things that i put in my mouth yeah
okay
no i feel you dude wait there's another
yeah there's another one of us
yeah yeah yeah we are the same uh but
yeah flavors it is
that i have an aunt that um actually
still still can't taste it's been six
months
no it has been six months and she still
can't taste
so that is insane to me and that can
happen i haven't heard it
lasting like over a week i wonder if
kovid
if there was like a disease that just
took your smell and taste away i wonder
if this country would have like taken it
more seriously
yeah you're never gonna be able to taste
or smell again
yeah all those people down in the south
who love barbecue and [ __ ] they're gonna
be like [ __ ]
top well you know you have the new
strand where some people are getting
blind
what yeah blind that isn't dying for it
just for a few days
but imagine you're like on the 101 and
your vision just starts to go out and
you're like wait
wait wait i'm just trying to get out
that's like my biggest fear is being
blind i think i know
yeah and temporary blindness just the
mental stress of not knowing if you're
going to be blind forever
would yeah imagine geez man my heart
goes out well and it's just coming like
out of nowhere it's like i could have
like trained
for this i would have counted steps in
my house
like you know i would have felt around
more yeah
a little bit better yeah
when we get back home let's memorize our
space don't take your eyes for granted
because it may not be there just like
rig that's
my room with little bells times like
these in unprecedented times like these
now more than ever we need to walk
around in the dark
and figure out where the corners are in
our house
right how many steps is your toilet from
your bed meg these are things
yeah we need to find the kitten bashing
coffee tables too
we know where those are you're gonna be
banging your shins all over the place
uh so what do you i mean outside of i
mean i guess cove is a part of this but
just
in general um you know given that it's
the new year
like 2021 what are you guys's biggest
and boldest predictions
for uh maybe for the the world and you
know
everything else but also for yourself
this year what
are you doing like goals as well maybe
some goals
yeah sprinkled in there go ahead nick me
yeah yeah you're doing one of the most
fascinating things right now
nick you're making why don't we do it at
the same time let's answer at the same
time
yeah yeah yeah answer at the same time
okay one two three nothing's gonna
change
everything's gonna change
it's all gonna be different yeah dude we
got a new president
we got a new strategy though yeah do we
i wouldn't be so yeah
like an ancient story only heard of in
like two in ten more days
oh man yeah like did you hear at one
point
i did just speaking of florida i did see
someone that carved trump's name
into a manatee yeah i said poor manatee
kind of person does such a thing
on its skin i know exactly the kind of
person a florida person
is
have you ever had that urge like are you
just like do you wake up with weird like
florida man
urges like in the middle of nowhere like
that i mean i i want to get a truck
sometimes
i want to walk barefoot everywhere
barefoot everywhere
although you can't do that here you go
just get drunk and like go hang out at a
gas station yeah like a thing
you want yeah okay yeah but like nothing
like that also the logistics
of carving anything into a manatee how
do you do it
because what you'd have to do is you
need to get a [ __ ] snorkel or
something
and go down into the water and find a
manatee that's like
i don't know sleeping asleep do they
even sleep they sleep like pounds
i think you had more manatees around you
than where i was okay are you saying
that you've never taken a saddle put it
on a manatee and
ridden it no i've done that of course
okay great of course wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait really you've done that
no yeah it's uh it's called manatee
wrangling
yeah is that a thing it's how you
tickets are only five dollars
that's how you tame a manatee
i can't tell if you're being serious
enough i would believe floridians to do
that
i'm not being serious but you're right
it's totally yeah i'm sure they do it
they do something probably what you do
is you take a horse saddle yeah
i think it's just one of those inlets um
on the florida coast
and uh he he accidentally
uh paddled his kayak over a manatee and
the thing
flipped his [ __ ] because it was it was
just like it got startled
and they have so much force behind them
because they're just like these giant
creatures
yeah they just like it just it looked
like a cannon
fire just like in the water yeah you're
just like
the whole thing went up in the air
probably like five feet in the air
oh wow yeah and that just swam away
if that happened that manatee was out
for blood but all the other ones are
real nice
i respect manatees but but you would
have to you would have to tie this thing
in some kind of restraint i know what
would you well
either that or it just didn't notice
because they have like this layer of
like protection on them so it might not
have even noticed that it was happening
are we sure that it was carved and it
wasn't like marker well there's also
when i say a layer they have i haven't i
know a lot about manatees
yeah tell me about their epidermal
layers matt they tell me more
they actually have a layer of algae
that's like pretty much permanently
affixed to their bodies they don't move
very much they're just algae and
barnacles and all kinds of stuff they're
kind of like whales in that way
so like barnacles are getting attached
to them algae turtles okay yeah
so so it's more like a relief that they
did with the trunk it was like they just
carved
yeah it's still you know animal abuse
that's still yeah don't put other
people's ideas on him
that is what if he's not trump yeah yeah
what if he's pro biden like you really
made your point there buddy
right hurting an innocent creature
manatee yeah why don't you let the
manatee speak for itself
exactly anyway
yeah they should have really let it
speak for itself and like given it the
knife
you know yeah like hey here you go buddy
what do you want to say you know
you're an elephant yeah for real red or
blue you only got two choices
here in america god all right well we
got everything's gonna change we got
nothing's
everything's staying the same yeah um
i mean you know the first you know like
i saw this meme it was like the seven
day free trial of 2021
like we want to return it like let's get
it out of here
it was like i'm good
but everyone was so looking forward to
2021 as in like they're like
oh i'm ready to put 20 20 behind me i'm
like
there's one second difference between 20
20 and 20 21 and like
what you were eating yesterday is still
in your body the next day
like your old habits they still carry
over
nothing's changed the government is
still doing their thing you know we've
gotten so much better this year
it's like you can just try to keep being
better but to think something's just
going to change because you say happy
new years and like come
that's true yeah yeah yeah obviously
that's the myth of every year
that people think that but it's a nice
opportunity i don't know there is
something also like to counter to
counterbalance that there is something
nice i think maybe you guys don't feel
this way but
i i like new year's at the end of the
year
that there's like the winter and the
reset
and like a i guess a time
to uh just kind of
re-evaluate and re-approach everything
that you're doing in
however means are necessary at that time
or for that year
yeah and and having a time to do that
whether that's in the middle of the
summer
or at the you know at the new year um
i just think it's really important for
everyone to have a time to do that
yeah and so that's kind of my time to do
that and that's what i enjoy about it
but
yeah obviously there's there's all that
hype around like oh
i'm gonna do this or my resolutions are
gonna be that and
obviously most of the time that's i feel
like it's the more resolutions you have
the less likely you are to stick to any
of them yeah
yeah for sure yeah and you know when you
set goals for the year you also need to
make a plan about how to achieve all
those goals too right it's not just like
i'm going to do this here's the bullet
points and then just forget about it or
put it on a piece of paper and you know
yeah
leave it on your feet yeah there's like
there's all those tiny micro steps in
between
yeah you know an actual goal and then
the the
steps that you actually need to take to
get there
um which are just you know everyday
things that
that you need to do or change or work on
yeah people forget about like internal
goals that like
just changing the way they think about
different things like you know
like some people their outlook of the
year was just like
super super pessimistic you know even
though a lot of bad stuff happened
people are just so ready to like throw
away 20 20 but i'm like well
every bad situation has it's good you
know you have to find the good and stuff
like
i got hired you know what i mean you
yeah even though you got coveted
happening you started making a
film you know but it's like it's a more
challenging way of doing it but you're
still
able to do it it's a great distraction
let me tell you yeah
and also i mean the fact that i got to
go back and spend two months with my
family living at home
like that's something i'm never going to
have again yeah
i mean right i don't want to say that
remember never say never who knows what
2021 has in store but
that's that was like that was a blessing
for me
yeah to be able to just like have
home-cooked meals and like
it felt like high school again or like
like growing up like childhood so
yeah i mean there's always two sides to
it yeah man
yeah and that's what orlando was for me
too so yeah yeah
people would like that's just super
important like um
you know um especially being where the
studio is being in
you know a huge city the second largest
city in america the 14th largest
metropolitan area on the planet
a huge international city like los
angeles
sometimes especially when you know
you're you're in that
pre having a family of your own phase
but but post
having coming out of the family that you
were in you know
there's like a it's
that stuff you know just just the
basics of like hey there's people that
love me and
that are around me and i get to spend
time with them
um is super important and
like you said nick i just think like
people having an opportunity to do that
and however it happened for them or if
it did happen
uh i don't know i just that's a really
good thing i think that came out of the
year
yeah you know especially in such
uncertain times god damn you
[Laughter]
in these uncertain times guys
all right wait what's the other one yeah
never more
crazy there's challenging times there's
some times
we should more than
[Laughter]
we should talk about our goals though as
well
what are your goals uh i got one for you
i i am going to learn cinema 4d this
year yeah
because i am a vfx artist that doesn't
know cinema 4d that's not
that's that's not right i can't even
call myself a vfx artist
[Music]
uh some some of that 3d what about
blender
uh blunders blender's cool i i feel like
just the
telling the integration with after
effects in cinema 4d is really nice for
me because i
i love after effects so much and i use
it all the time so
i think that's probably a good a better
place for me to start
um okay that's gonna happen it's gonna
happen for sure so years
what's your plan
yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah that's
that's the goal um well so
first of all you have uh just this
wealth of knowledge at corridor
right and and learning from them is
great
but my motivators are usually forcing
myself to do stuff
so if i put myself in a position where i
have to do it
because of this this or this then i'm
gonna do it for sure
especially if the deadlines are really
tight and stuff like that uh so what i'm
going to do
is i've already shot a music video in
orlando i directed a music video
and i intentionally made a visual effect
in there that has to be a cg
element no and i'm going to use cinema
4d i'm going to learn it because i have
to learn it because i have to turn it
around at a certain point yeah
so so that's it that's that's that's
really smart man
i admire that like that's that's a
really good way to
to to force yourself to to take yourself
to the next level like you
you you you do 90
of the things that you know how to do
yeah and then you you
when you're doing something and then you
give yourself that 10 where it's like
well i've never done that before
but i'm gonna do it in this project
where i'm gonna do it in this
work and yeah i don't know you know i
know
90 of it i already know i know how to do
but that that
that one i'm going to save that's super
yeah
and it's like it's also it's about
knowing yourself too and knowing what
you know being honest with yourself
about like okay this goal is going to be
hard to achieve
because i know that i also wouldn't just
make myself do it for no reason
yeah like even if it's something i
really want to do it's a lot harder for
me
personally to like just make myself do
that stuff
but if like i said if it's something
where it's like i got to do it there's
no
there's no other choice i've put myself
in this position where i have to do it
then it's gonna it's gonna happen um and
i'll work i'll work you know
late hours to make it happen you know
we're kind of going through that right
now with
um functional filmmaking and son of a
dungeon
on the website uh we when we originally
put those two shows out there uh we had
never done
uh like a proper um
it's it's it's entertainment but it's
it's almost like how master class is
entertainment
in the sense that it's it's it's
in-depth kind of insider baseball
knowledge but it's
it's presented in a way that you can
still just watch it and appreciate it
and understand why it's important but
also if you if you want to get deeper
into it or you know more about
it it still makes sense um
and we'd never done anything like that
before so
we'd done tutorials you know or and we'd
done like live we did some live
tutorials like on
twitch when twitch was first a thing and
and we did some
other few odds and ends but we've never
done anything like that
and so we thought it would be
kind of straightforward but in the back
of my mind i kind of knew like uh
there's still a 10
or a 15 element to this show that none
of us
have ever done before like and i think
in the writing process
that's when really things started to
show that hey
guys we've never written anything like
this because i mean nick your episode
we ended up filming it last because what
we were trying to do was
uh connect the filming of a corridor
crew video
with your lesson
and so we kind of had to wait for like
the right moment for those things to
align but then
also at the same time your your lesson
was about
how to make a show out of anything and
so
it's like a full circle yeah so so we
in the process of making his episode we
had to adhere to the
to the to our own advice of the
episode oh man in the sense of like
following the story
even though we had planned to shoot it a
certain way that didn't work out and so
we then had to follow a different story
and shoot it that way
um and so that was that was really
interesting and then when with son of a
dungeon
uh yeah sure we did a dnd show we did
two i think on node back in the day but
um they were way just
more rudimentary and so all of the bells
and whistles of like
you know high quality lighting and like
uh
motion graphics and and and visual
elements and
audio and like uh visual
sound and music cues and lighting cues
in the background and all that stuff
that we want to go into like the game
itself um we've never done before
and now we're two weeks away from three
weeks away from filming this and i
we're running into all those problems
but it's only because we just set the
days of like okay we're gonna film it on
february 3rd
like doesn't matter come hell or high
water so
let's go and um
see what happens but we're definitely in
that we're in that weird space where
we've never done it before
in this capacity season two is gonna be
great dude
season two is gonna be perfect no but i
mean like all jokes aside
it's gonna be a learning process as
you're saying like
i was just talking with ren the other
day we were like talking about how you
motivate yourself to learn stuff
yeah he's like you have to have a
specific project you have to have
another goal
that you're doing and this goal is like
a sub goal
like learn that thing for this thing
yeah yeah
because it has to come from a selfish
place yeah
likely yeah you know i need to yeah i
mean that's how we're all motivated
so for sure having that first season of
son of a dungeon you're gonna learn a
lot
but we got carmichael he's like the dnd
yeah pro
yeah so yeah we're really really lucky
to to have him on this because
everything he's done over the last
well really four years has prepared him
kind of for this particular show you
know he spent three years with us
making vlogs and and then you know
basically building up
the foundation with you nick of what the
quarter crew channel is today
and then he went out did his own d d
show and now
all of those things are coming back
together for son of a dungeon oh yeah
i can't wait for that yeah that's cool
man it's really it's gonna be great man
it's gonna be great i wrote my character
up last week um
you know so i don't know if you guys are
into d d but i'm gonna
nerd out for a second i'm playing are
you are these some sneak peeks
sneak peeks oh exclusive playing as a
half elf
uh ranger um
yeah okay so we got that going golf
ranger
what is that what it what's your name
yeah my name is
let me get my character sheet hold on
nick let me get my character sheet
give us your name jakey get your sheet
man you were going to ask what a ranger
you know why would one want to be an elf
ranger like
what good components half ounce ranger
yeah not just we're talking half elves
here i've got my players handbook here
okay okay my
uh character's name is jadar ithara
yes it is yeah he's he's a half elf
uh what's that spelled backwards
probably the same
and um he's uh he's urethra
his family business he's his family
business was in
uh he's a repo man actually oh
stuff um half elves are known as
wanderers and and diplomats and um
you know so he's also a ranger so he's
really good at tracking
and uh hunting and investigating and
he's a little stealthy
you know and so he's the guy that you
call like if you need something back
you know um he's that guy so
yeah i i think it's going to be
interesting i think it's a good
foundation for
characters freddie uh hopefully is
joining us uh
d is joining us as a witch hunter and
uh and nico is joining us as a classic
nico character a charming
bard character porsche yeah a bartender
music
a music man yeah yeah uh with his
handpan oh yeah yeah a handpan for days
yeah yeah the goldilock
bards are famous for their ability to um
charm and uh and uh you know swindle
um cast aura of chill for yes
yeah so that's gonna be
that's gonna be good looking forward to
that hell yeah man
so nick your movie is days away from
rapping
just days just four long days
and then and then three long weeks in
between that
to get there did now did you i heard a
rumor
that you're that part of this movie is
in portuguese yeah part of it wait what
would you hear that where's this stuff
where's the stuff getting there i didn't
tell them around
uh oh oh yeah dude carmichael's like
he saw that scene he's like screw this
so can you talk about that can you why
like why or is it part of the see is the
whole thing in no
no the whole thing isn't but okay the
the brief rundown and
i can i've been trying not to talk too
much about the movie because it's not
done yet and if
you talk about your goals yeah if i talk
about my goals it makes but
you know it gets them motivated like
it's better to save it up until the end
i feel like yeah
you know what i mean like just tell them
where the portuguese part so the
portuguese part
say it in portuguese the the main
actress god if only i could
the main actresses is from portugal and
she also
is has the story by credit for the film
so she had the original idea
it's it's a film about human trafficking
uh it's about a girl who gets
catfished and then drugged and kidnapped
uh so it's like a really [ __ ] up road
trip film basically
um she's being taken to go get sold
essentially
yeah and has to find a way to escape and
she is from
her character is also from portugal so
you know
her character is it's based heavily on
her but
yeah the movie was uh inspired by one of
her friends
from i think denmark i think
one of those scandinavian countries up
there who was actually trafficked
for like a year she heard the story from
her and that kind of inspired the idea
of the original script so sure yeah so
part of it is in portuguese and
it's kind of hard to direct people when
you don't speak
their language especially like i know i
know some spanish i can get around in
spanish but
yeah it's nothing like spanish i know
it's not
yeah it's like it's like if a spanish
and dutch person just melded like yeah
yeah
like it's very weird yeah i dated a
brazilian girl and
i had no doubt that their family was
trash talking me
their sounds even because they did no
more different yeah brazilian portuguese
is totally different than how
i don't know they just didn't like me
really
[Laughter]
they just like don't even try to hide
the
you should have just recorded them one
night while you were there and then like
took it home they're like
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah just have your
translator going the technology wasn't
there yet
voice recording should have done it what
no no the the voice translate
so wow so that was probably
i mean not only was that probably
interesting just in the scene of trying
to direct people in portuguese but also
like
in in in diving into the script
and getting into the story and the
backstory of the film itself i mean
um that's a really dark subject to to to
utilize for for the piece so yeah my
assumption is you learned a few things
about that along the way as well
i mean a little bit man like
like sorry do you mean about like the
subject matter or about trump
human trafficking oh yeah dude no it's
there's there's been a lot of
documentaries and articles
watched and read and yeah a lot of most
of what happens in the film is like
based on
real accounts it's just all put into one
movie you know
so like her experience is probably
elevated past what an
a victim would go through because
there's all these things happening but
like
it definitely is like a real life horror
movie of just like all this [ __ ] going
on
one thing after another real life
scarier than hormones yeah honestly
yeah we thought this was going to be a
thriller at first like
you know oh it's thrilling but like
after shooting it like scene after
intense scene you're just like
oh this is going to be hard to watch
like yeah but i think in a good way sure
sure yeah uh it's a horrible did you
make sure did you write the script or
did you
not know the screenplay i didn't write
the original screenplay but i rewrote it
like like i did rewrites with the
original writer who's also
my co-producer right well that's awesome
man i mean do you have an idea on
in terms of like when you think it'll be
done
so we're gonna wrap by the end of the
month we got as i said like four more
days and then one more like
a couple more pick up days so and then
post we're trying to have we just found
an editor for it
so that's gonna be awesome um we'll
start seeing some edits here in the next
couple months and then hopefully by like
mid to late summer we'll have a final
cut of the thing so yeah
yeah wow that's my goal for this year
awesome so do you just like
when you're when you're doing posts my
my assumption you break things down
just kind of by scene at the end of it
and then you render it and then you
render each scene
yeah and slap it together so we're
shooting in 6k so we're doing proxies
which
for anyone who doesn't edit a proxy is
when you take your really high quality
uh like shot basically your file
and you render each file out as a really
low quality one well this case 1080. so
it's like you know if it's 4k what is
that like a fourth of the quality
or something really bad at that stuff
but so the editor will work with the low
quality like footage and then at the end
all the all the names of the files will
be the same so you just reconnect it to
the high quality ones for all of your
exports so
that's gonna make that easy but as far
as how the actual
scenes and stuff are assembled like
we're gonna start with scenes that are
crucial to
us raising more money to get this thing
finished because there's going to be
more costs
involved in post-production such as a
dialogue mixer
super important don't think that's
important but you want that [ __ ] to
sound crispy up on the screen
yeah you know music those are the two
big things
um and we're trying to pay people on
points on the back end but
a lot of these things you know it's
covered right now a lot of people can't
work for points
because that's a risk so yeah i mean
hopefully if we assemble some like
really intense scenes
that get across the vive of the movie we
can show that to possible investors
and get another round of funding sure
for distribution right
yeah yeah and that's yeah that's a whole
other beast
so this is just i'm learning everything
along the way
i'm learning so much it's pretty like my
brain is full
but it's uh it's good stuff to know so
awesome
so yeah that's great man i'd love to see
when you get some scenes assembled i'd
love to see it yeah and just see
see kind of how that's all coming
together me too dude i can't wait to see
something cut i haven't seen anything
cut yet
we have like hours of dailies but just
you're in that scary post like please
post post shoot pre-edit
then you're like waking up at night in
cold sweats going oh my god did i get
that did i get that reaction i don't
know if i did oh god
oh yeah luckily i'm feeling better
about it than i have most projects after
like that post shoots
stress sweats is a little bit less this
time so
okay good just kidding i've been able to
like
have a good team behind it don't worry i
don't have to do it as soon as you
receive the first draft it'll all come
back to you
yeah it goes back to that scorsese quote
right
it's something along the lines of like
if you don't
like get sick after watching the first
cut of your film then you're doing
something wrong it's not
paraphrasing but it's like something
like so that gives me solace
in that yeah yeah if scorsese gets sick
yeah dude i mean yeah
yeah i once had someone tell us after
reviewing a first
cut of some work we did for them uh i
had somebody tell us
ah what did they say in exact words um
i hate it it makes my eyes hurt
oh good notes thank you thank you
i said okay great yeah i'll uh get
started
we'll work on making your eyes hurt less
thank you
thank you for that dude don't get
discouraged man
yeah no i i think uh you know i got a
lot of
awesome people surrounding me in
corridor here who
i hope to be getting really cool notes
from eventually on this thing
so yeah yeah yeah like that's that's
yeah that's
one thing that we can definitely do you
know and then
um who knows i mean if it's something
that's like
having not seen it or read the script or
anything like but if it's something
where we see it and it's
and there's a real attachment to it you
know
um who knows maybe maybe we can do more
on the on the post side yeah man yes
definitely open to that and then we're
gonna need all the help we can get so
it's uh definitely open to those
conversations sweet
yeah can't wait to show you guys
something mm-hmm
yeah yeah but moving on to your goals
yeah this year yeah you're not escaping
this
committee of corridor officially by the
way yeah yeah yeah definitely
you definitely are the fact that the
fact that you
set out a table for the secret santa
i mean just the fact that there was a
surface a clean surface to place the
presents on
not not even to mention the hawaiian
barbecue yeah i mean yeah
and the snacks the third table because
then i had the snack table during the
live stream oh yeah you did we had a
covered safe socially distanced hawaiian
barbecue end-of-year party and jordan
like transformed the backyard
into a whole new world yeah i literally
i didn't recognize it i saw some of the
photos
uh and i didn't recognize it at first i
was like where are they where did they
go
yeah we totally forgot we just went back
there and we're like yeah we could do
this
and i was like putting up more lights i
remember matt was like sit
down no you're done like there must be
more christmas time
on
there's friday enough cheer not enough
holiday chairs dude there were like
candles going and everything
and oh yeah and billy lit his hair on
fire oh
my god did we not talk about that
i don't know that i feel like i feel
like we should let ren
explain this one like we gotta ah no
no why don't we hear both sides of the
story no no we gotta tell them
can come on next week and he can defend
himself but right now you gotta tell the
story
i'll just start by saying i decided to
do something
simple nice you know some cute candles
spread throughout
the backyard really create that ambiance
you know
i was like if anything's gonna happen
yeah me and christian were worried about
the wires from all of the um
christmas lights and we're trying to
connect them and gaff tape them down
we're like because no one's about to get
hurt on our watch
meanwhile not even the issue we get
[Laughter]
so basically it's like i think ren
leaned down to
to grab a beer from a cooler right and
and
here's the i took a csi crime scene
photo yeah
god dude show me so so ren lane's down
to grab this beer
and i see out of the corner of my eye
just a glow like a like an orange glow
that just is not
just does not make sense for a candle to
be doing that i look over
and i'm like red your hair's on fire
his hair was literally engulfed in
flames part of it straight up spongebob
character and run it out and build it
straight up like
it smells so bad oh yeah i didn't
realize how bad burnt hair smelled like
rubber
yeah i learned that when bullies lit my
hair on fire in middle school
i learned how to oh yeah what
are you serious yeah i'm serious yeah so
that gives me flashbacks
but back to this ren i'm not sure if the
camera can see this
here's a here's a recreation
with there's the candle it was perfectly
positioned
right where you'd have to reach down to
get a beer for the cooler
and but did he not like see the candle
no one ever put their hair on fire he
just stuck his hair right in the candle
like he just was not looking at it i
think that if there was a cooler
and then there were candles on the edge
of the cooler or anywhere near the edge
of the cooler that
you wouldn't like say if this my desk is
the cooler you wouldn't take your head
and like put it yeah yeah i just i
imagine he's just such a tall man
that the world is different for him yeah
instead of the jank it's like he has to
deal with the link
yeah yeah he's just linking all over
there's some ipa's going around
yeah we had some ideas around there was
some light going around and then
when ren is a couple ipas deep i've
noticed he starts moving it on
axis more like i'll like kind of do this
i'll be like what's up guys how are you
doing and then like i think he was just
like grabbing a beer like this he's like
[Music]
straight into the candle yeah the toast
toasty red moves like this
well toasted oh yeah so that was a
highlight
god bless him and his hair was high that
was that was like
dude him passing out and that in this
yeah seriously two months yeah
2020 wasn't all bad we got that out of
it
no we got that out of it for sure
so we can laugh about it okay what are
your goals i do have goals
i do promise okay hashtag goals
hashtag goals so i live with my roommate
obviously and we our goal for this year
is to learn
filmmaking as much as possible watch as
many films as possible
we're gonna get our first camera here
within the next couple days
and really just learn how to work it
everything play around with it go walk
around you know what i mean we're trying
to learn lighting sound
so we're also trying to look into which
labs we want to start working with
because you know like
i know about lavalier mics and receivers
but until you actually start like using
it and like
knowing what's going to screw up your
video or you know what i mean like
just actually using it i'm like breaking
down stuff here all the time and i'm
seeing people use it
but until it's an actual like project
i'm doing and i'm like
just going through the motions that's
what it takes to learn you know so
that's what we're doing we're going to
be
in our apartment going through the
motions all of 2021
and you know making little content
pieces like here and there that we can
just like throw up on instagram
the point is just get used to doing
stuff you know yeah just do as much as
possible
but like that's great that's awesome
that's super cool to hear
like that's that's gonna give you so
much more
information on the other side and
knowledge on the other side
that and the nice thing is uh if
you are familiar with nico's how to
master any camera episode on functional
filmmaking
um that's exactly what it's about though
it's it's about
once you master the fundamentals of of
of you know basic camera
how it takes in light what it does with
it and how to use the settings to
capture it
you can then take that and apply it to
all these different types of cameras
for specific styles uh
that you're looking to get right because
you can easily get like
you know overwhelming when you just
think of everything that encompasses
film so we're like okay no we're not
going to sit here and try and learn
about every camera we're going to get a
camera
and we're going to learn everything we
can about that camera and then
we'll take that knowledge and move it
towards another camera
and then figure out what else we need to
learn about that camera yeah and in the
process of doing that you'll figure out
what its strengths and weaknesses are
yeah um and then you'll know what to
look for in the next one
yeah um i just rewatched the why the
black magic
is like their favorite when they're
testing it out yeah and him and nico
and how they were saying well i was
looking at a lot of like different vlogs
too on
youtube they're saying that black magic
is the poor man's red
is so good though like because i like
the raw footage and all of that
so i think we might go with black magic
really yeah i mean
we got we got like a stack of them over
there
honestly you should we do a little
domino pile we have like two
minis which are awesome the four k the
pocket yeah the pocket
yeah and then you have been learning so
basically if you swipe one we'll never
notice
perfect i mean i am i'm the one that
keeps christian
[ __ ] she has the keys christian will
notice you shot down that joke
real quick yeah that's a that's a
i mean that's gonna give the nice thing
about the blackmagic is it's
it's a big you can learn on it but it's
also got a
it's got a bent towards a cinema camera
in
in a lot of its features and it's os and
a few other
things so you won't necessarily fall
into some of the
like dslr conventions
that then you have to break or get out
of when you move to a cinema camera it
won't it won't do that as much to you
it'll still do that to you a little bit
but
at the same time with the way that those
things are and the direction that
they're going you may never
encounter that problem because yes well
well it certainly started as the poor
man's read every
iteration that they release and come out
with like
it more and more just becomes a great
camera
um uh so yeah that's not not a bad
choice at all and then really just comes
down to what kind of glass
you put on it yeah um you know what kind
of lens you put on it
that's what we say glass because you
know we're in this room
yeah yeah and then once you start doing
and then you got to start doing this
oh yeah dude if you don't have this as
your profile picture
you're not a director yeah this is what
it says yeah this
thing you get you do the directors yeah
yeah this is when you're like this is
like
flipping the world or like this is where
the camera is just
yeah and then this is this how how wide
your fingers are indicates your field of
view
it's like this and then your caption is
perspective
yeah also quiet coyote yeah also quiet
coyote no but i mean that part
[Laughter]
that could be a good directing tip too
for the crew like all right
everyone quiet coyotes
well you're in the right place to learn
everything about film
here yeah i know i'm anytime i encounter
a problem i mean i all the
matt will tell you how many times i text
and i'm like hey what's this what's that
what's that
it's a lot it's a lot
but yeah i mean that's the great thing
that matt was saying everyone's so
knowledgeable here and i can go up to
anyone and everyone's just gonna give me
as much as they know
and they love to do it you know yeah and
that's gonna come right back around and
like help you here
yeah yeah like i like i can go to you
can go up to anyone at any point in time
no one's gonna get like irritated that
i'm asking them a question
if anything they're just excited to
share their knowledge with the same
stuff that we love you know yeah what's
your
goal then because your goal is yeah what
your goal is to learn all the things
yeah why yeah how do you want to how do
you want to bring that about
live my life well i have an idea of how
my life would go
um well i would love like my own
production company when i'm older
like i love having like the whole
in-house feel
but i wanted to be a traveling
production company so like
you i want to move out of the states at
some point like
in my 30s and i want each location
to be where we do it doesn't like
there's no like time
put like smart so but say if we want to
do like a short film or a film
our first place is thailand we'll we all
live in an airbnb
together we wake up we film but then i
also want to hire locally
so like my roommate is has a social work
job and she's getting her master's in
social work so we want to kind of
combine
both of those do a lot of documentaries
about homelessness and just
everything around the world so we want
to help people every time we go to a new
location
hire locally and then yeah once that
project's done then we go to like the
next location that we want to go film
so then you just have all these
different places that you get to like
work with
you get to meet a bunch of different
people you get to experience life
while doing what you're passionate about
it's awesome that's
my idea of what my life is going to look
like
yeah yeah i mean traveling the world
yeah and then just going
out yeah that is a goal no kidding so
yeah and until then i
like love my life right now i'm just
learning everything
for cool you know years just yeah
everything will
happen when it's supposed to send us
postcards from egypt
hey guys postcards from egypt yeah
we gotta go we're on yeah it's like this
and matt and i are just screaming
i mean i'm going to be almost in your
position of just trying to learn how to
do like films and stuff
nothing's going to be so easy you said
documentary but you think narrative's a
part of that we want to do both
documentaries like shorts and little
dogs and stuff and i would love to just
always kind of keep it new and fresh
which is why i would love to
change the location each project you
know you get
a different view you get a different
culture you know what i mean you're
working with different people you're
working with different places you kind
of
already have to change up what you're
going to be putting out
immediately just because of all of those
work with what you have really
yeah it's like one of those uh 48-hour
film festivals
um
you know film in 48 hours and they have
like week-long ones they have 24-hour
ones
there's all sorts but yeah you get a
prompt like hey have a fish
a pillow and uh someone has to say
jeffrey
in your film and then you have to write
a script about that
and that's within the time limit and
then make it and then edit it and
deliver it but
this sounds kind of like that like you'd
have like an idea for a script but like
you're
you're hiring locally casting locally
basically
work with local locations yeah yeah
that's cool and the cool thing too it's
like essentially you will have like a
place of living like an airbnb that
everyone's with
feels like if anyone wants to come join
at all you know what i mean it's like oh
they're gonna fly out and on the next
project because we're probably gonna be
in like
europe i don't know
so poor yeah that's part of the fun
the corridor boys out to help out
honestly
the one whales have landed yeah right
that's how we like see like my like
there's a plane that lands and
the back of the plane opens
literally like the avengers yeah yeah we
all have cameras like
sliders and [ __ ] that's a freaking goal
right there
invasion let's get a company
that we can use to support jordan's
traveling production
that allows us to one wheel on and off
the plane
and on the plane too why not but never
have to check a battery again
yeah dude yeah yeah oh man
goals goals yeah yeah i mean yeah it was
a
it's a pretty big goal that's awesome
but that's
it's lofty but even if you even if you
don't land there
i'm sure there's a bunch of things that
you will learn that will put you where
you want to be
in the process of of approaching
something near or like that
yeah yeah you know everything's a
snowball effect you think you want
something
and then you start i didn't ever think i
was going to be at a production
company right now i thought i was just
going to come to la and act and then i
quickly learned was like this ain't it
like really well so let's rewind it a
little bit hold on
so you you you i think you're the only
person ever
who thought that they would come to la
and act yeah
yeah i think that's i think right i know
and then hold on it's not the move
suggests well you know for some people
yes
there are some people that love acting
so much and it's their own the only
thing they want to do
that's great sure for me i quickly
learned i mean the only reason i'm even
here now is because i know wes
so wes is basically the reason why i
even got this job because he
was like what's up jordan i was like i
need a job i remember i was like going
through it
and then like acting like wasn't like
it's not
there for you like you think it's gonna
yeah especially during covid too
yeah it feels a little bit like you're
you're
submitting to the lottery every time
like as a job as a profession it's
lottery because i did acting in
in when i lived really atlanta yeah for
a while and it does it just feels like
ever you submit
all of these things and you get maybe
one of uh
you know a month yeah you like barely
did like anything
yeah but it's like i love it but being
fortunately i got to be around people
like wes who create
and do other things and i didn't know
that
that was possible that people were out
here like
doing other stuff other than acting and
i started seeing this and i was like
would be with them on set helping them
out and i started falling in love with
the idea of
there's more to movies than the actors
there's
all these other moving parts behind the
camera don't tell the actors that
they're
beautiful so
i'm like no i want to learn how to do
all of this stuff and then it's just
crazy that it just happened
like that i was already falling in love
with the production side of things
and then wes was like hey there's like
they're looking for this person out of
production i was like what i was like
okay
yeah like i've already kind of like that
was my next move was to make sure i just
kept
getting on set so i could learn about
production it's very
serendipitous i think yeah that is
yeah you're you is well but acting's
cool
i just meant like that's not the only
thing i want to do
i already did it and now i can apply it
you know whenever i want yeah
to be an actor to be an actor and have a
successful career
it's probably i mean probably one of the
best jobs you can get in the film
industry but it's so hard
not many can do yeah and it's there's so
many things that go into it it's not
like talent i feel like it's like luck
mostly for sure
because like even if even if you get the
role in the like big film
you gotta it has to be successful like
so everyone else has to be doing their
[ __ ]
right on their a game like it's just
yeah i mean
i'm sure i could maybe sometimes get a
little boring maybe like
i think that's why i need it's hard i
mean other things like
if you're just acting then you just go
home you don't have anything else to
like work on you think you know what i
mean
unless you're like reading the script
for the next day on set
but like us we're always doing so many
different things like
if you write something you're probably
gonna have to act on it
and do some lighting and do some sound
and do some editing and
that is just so fun but i know obviously
like not
a lot of people think that way they you
know they want one job
that makes it happy less chaotic think
about we're psychos honestly oh yeah
stuff that we're just like always doing
and wearing all these hats
because honestly that just it breeds
like
film empathy on set and like
now when you're an actor on your next
set you're gonna know
hey lighting dude like i respect that
guy
yeah like camera guy i respect him
because i know it goes into it
and same for anything the more you know
the better you are i think yeah and the
better you can communicate with those
people too yeah
yes definitely absolutely guys and i
think in
in times like these now more than ever
bastard um well i don't know is there
anything else to hit on
uh on this uh on this episode ladies and
gentlemen ladies and gentlemen
so much ground and so little time sounds
like a great like it's been an hour and
a half wow yeah this just flew by
and you know what so i'm so honored that
you can all join us
today i'm talking to the audience no not
to you guys
we're by ourselves right this isn't
going to happen we're in front of a live
audience
this isn't going to air right this yeah
broadcast radio signal here we are i
didn't know we were taping currently
we're doing one of these live though i'm
just saying that yeah
that's actually thank you for reminding
me that's what i wanted to mention
um i've got two ideas for live shows for
uh the website and then they'll hit the
website first and then they'll also be
available on youtube
uh yeah one one of them is just live
podcasts
um so let us know in the comments if you
want to see a live podcast
uh rather than a pre-recorded one it's
something we've been talking about for
like six
eight months now then second idea
tell me if you guys like this uh we do
maybe it's like once every other week
you know depending on how much time we
can fit it in
it would be nice to do it once a week
but that might be a little too ambitious
it's a live music and
filmmaking question and answer hour
um where where basically it's like
i don't know if you guys are familiar
but there used to be this old show
called car talk saturday morning
dude i love car talk yes son yes yes it
was a super super popular radio show
back in the
i mean all the way up to the to the to
the 90s late into early 2000s
um and what they used to do was people
would call in
and they'd say hey i'm having trouble
with my car
and this is what's going on with it and
the guys who were the hosts were former
car mechanics
and so what they would do is they like
they were super charismatic and they
would just joke and like answer the
person's question and then in between
questions and answers they would play
music uh
and then they'd answer the next question
so i want to do something like that but
for
for for like digital filmmaking where
people
either through a forum or you know
through call uh
talk to us and then we answer their
question then we play songs in between
i think it'd be super fun that's that's
awesome you mean like play songs or like
play no no we play we play we'll play
songs like a drum circle no not
not like a drum no no actual thing no
jams yeah
like we we will we will select songs
gotcha
probably probably most probably mostly i
mean
i'd like to just have it be country in
western
[Music]
i just think there would be a fun blend
between like new new tech and old
timey style stuff you know that would be
a nice like
mashup for a show like that so
that's just my that's one of my hopes
hopes and dreams this year guys
yeah that's that's a fun one that would
be a lot of fun dreams
keep having them keep having them if if
uh
maybe we can put it on green light and
yeah people can why not yeah people can
green light it
okay i have that all right well until
next time
gentlemen folks how nice thank you all
for watching
thank you for watching you're here i'm
gonna play us out
oh as he does as i do
jordan's backstory is now canon universe
let's green light yeah your origin story
all right now we all have to like act
like we're like laughing and stuff is
like yeah
[Music]